hi I'm Gwen Ifill of PBS I'm here today
on c-span afterwards joined by Gail
Collins the first editorial page editor
woman editorial page editor of the New
York Times and currently columnist the
New York Times and the new author of
when everything changed the amazing
journey of American women from 1960 to
the present Gail Collins welcome thank
you I had to start by just asking the
obvious question what changed nothing
nothing at all it's been very exactly
the same you know I gotta tell you this
this sort of started this whole project
when I was um at the times and with the
Millennium was coming and you know
millennium retrospective --zz were
happening and we had war over the last
thousand years in peace over the last
thousand years and what you came over
the last thousand years whatever and the
magazine did one on women over the last
thousand years and they asked me to do
the introduction and when I did it and
it's I'm dim that I had not really
thought about this before I thought wow
the vision of really at base what women
are capable of doing and what their
limitations are and what their place in
the world is was not a base much
different 1960 than it was in the year
1000 and that historic visions of women
that have existed forever you know
changed in my lifetime we're just
smashed in my little lifetime which is a
tiny second and all this and it just
knocked me out and I knew I really
wanted to write about that but you could
have written about this in a very and
I'm happy to say it's not a dry book at
all it's very engaging thank you and you
could have written about it that way you
could have just written a history of the
American woman since 1960 instead you
got voices in it you talked to the women
who actually lived it that seems to make
the difference you have to you have to
tell things in a story it has to be the
stories it's always the stories that
drive things and I'm also a person who
will if I look at a picture the Magna
Carta being signed I really want to know
like what kind of shoes they were where
they went to the bathroom and you know
how were they happy so that's stuff you
know what the fact that we couldn't wear
pants in 1960 you know the girdle thing
and the empty orange juice you're going
to be people younger than you
I watching this program and they may not
know what you mean by the girdle thing
for instance this was a huge cesarean
that matter repression for yes oh it was
terrible the book starts with us with
Louise Rabinowitz who in 1960 was kicked
out of the terrific court of Manhattan
for attempting to pay a parking ticket
while wearing slacks for her boss not
even yes it was her boss's ticket and
that the the magistrate was just furious
that the dignity of the traffic court
had been so violated by this woman
wearing slacks walking in and poor Lois
got her husband who had only been
married to over two weeks of the time to
come and pay the ticket and the judge
yelled at the husband and said you'd
better clamp down this young woman
before it's too late and that was so
much so many the women I talked to said
it was such a pain to always have to
wear a skirt everywhere and you really
did and this judge also said he objected
to her to her taking herself off this
pedestal
right he had women on right you need it
you couldn't have a pedestal and wear
slacks you wanted to be on the pedestal
you had to wear a skirt that was all it
was because you could what look under
the skirt is good about tennis know that
I've always loved is the idea of putting
somebody in a pedestal you are up high
but you cannot move at all you are
really stuck right there you can't get
down if you choose can't get down if you
choose to and this becomes a running
theme actually I just a skip ahead I
want to talk about the pants politics
because I think we're both wearing
slacks today we're comfortable you know
have Mira liberated women but you know
what this kept coming up over and over
again it's like almost a running theme
and you know when I was writing the book
I realized that when I was in college we
were not allowed to leave the dorm
wearing slacks unless we were going
bowling and there was so much alleged
bowling going on at Marquette University
I cannot tell you but it was and women
who won't work for the post office told
me you know that they had to wear it you
know we could think of worse likes to
work but then you had to change into a
skirt and of course if you had a skirt
on then you had to wear nylons this is
before pantyhose were invented had to
wear nylons and with the nylons to hold
them up you had to wear a girl and I
also talked to so many women who when
they were kids going to high school when
they were teeny skinny little girls
had to wear these girdles when they were
on their way to school it was an you
know an incredibly restricting thing and
there is something about the way women
dressed over the centuries that that
there was a sense that you're not going
to be moving around a whole lot we got
you here that was a design but you know
you met you write about something that
Richard Nixon in 1973 said to Helen
Helen Thomas and said Helen are you
comfortable in those pants I know women
in China I saw wearing them but it
really bothers me very much
I can't imagine Helen Thomas took that
very well well you know but I'm sure
that the past day yeah let's talk about
the moments over time over these 50
years that you write about that that
switched the light on for a lot of women
there were obviously the Abarth ones but
let's start with some of the the ones
I've considered to be more subtle like I
didn't really consider how much birth
control the easy availability of birth
control change women and had more to do
with liberating women been any March so
huge it was so huge because until then
you know but limited always women are no
dopes they've always used birth control
but until the pill the stuff that you
could get or use was really very helpful
if your goal was to have three children
rather than 12 children but if your goal
was to not get pregnant at all it was
really not reliable and it was only
there's some wonderful charts that some
sociologists have done showing that just
as the pill became readily available
which was really not until later in the
60s nearly 70s for single women as it
became available applications to medical
schools and law schools just shot up
because how could you commit yourself to
careers that are going to take you a
decade maybe to get going if you're not
really sure that you can stop from
getting pregnant so by allowing women to
delay childbearing all kinds of
opportunities yeah totally and
absolutely pill is huge it also
empowered women sexually yeah the whole
the sexual you know there are so many
revolutions in the 1670s actual
revolution was and it was really all
about women it was about ending the
double standard because there had always
been the presumption that men had the
right to go out and try to have sex and
enjoy themselves but
we're supposed to be chaste until they
got married and of course to protect
your chastity you wanted to get married
early otherwise more dangers would arise
and once you're married of course if you
don't have the pill then you're going to
get pregnant so it all sort of squished
in together and if you actually
committed yourself to a career before
all these changes happened it was like
taking the veil you know I will see no
man you know I'm going to spend the next
20 years of my life becoming a doctor
but men beware I'm none like my virtue
out there and so that was just huge
women had more choices all kinds of wigs
but so often the economy was the dictate
of whether a woman had a choice or not
you went out to work because you may had
gone to war in Vietnam war or because
you just couldn't afford anymore to stay
at home yeah in poor women had always
worked we developed this nice tidy myth
that women did not work particularly
after they were married women did not
work after they were married unless you
were poor and then you did but nobody
paid any attention to you anyway and the
the myth in the 50s and the 60s that you
know all housewives stayed home with
their children was a myth that was
created by basically upper-middle class
people but it is true that that was the
vision of the good life the good life
was if you didn't work and you were a
success if you managed to marry a guy
who did so well that he could support
you and miraculously there was this one
glorious window of opportunity after
World War Two in which a family really
could achieve this brand-new Wow
spectacular lifestyle that no nation in
the world had ever given on a wide scale
to its people before you could have a
house you could have a car
TV continues left college you could go
to the suburbs
you could do all this on one person
salary because inflation was so low
salaries were going up the rest of the
world was really not coming out of the
the war yet and they were really not
competing we were creating all the
wealth of the planet practically at that
point we were doing so well men of
course got veterans benefits low income
loans everything was fantastic for about
10-15
years there this worked really well then
the 70s came you could no longer support
a family on that kind of level with one
pet one paycheck so the women went to
work and they never stopped and you know
I find all this really liberating in a
way because it's really troubling to me
that we tend to look back at our history
and say well women were oppressed they
were so weak they were such wimps and
then suddenly in our lifetimes we became
strong and invincible are always strong
we were always strong and invincible and
if it was just having good leaders you
know susan b anthony would have taken
care of this sucker you know before the
Civil War it's the other stuff the
economy if you were in a farm based
society the role of the housewife the
farm housewife and the traditional
farmhouse so it was a very empowered
role and she was going very
labour-intensive very and she created
wealth and the whole family knew she was
creating wealth and actually we have
some because there are women that my
researchers interviewed in Wyoming who
were living colonial-style lives in the
1960s but they loved it and their
children look back on it is this great
time and their husbands respected them
they worked their little fingers off but
they really felt empowered but that life
went away all that stuff is gone now
isn't what we liked it or not it's not
there and this new society that we were
created was one that challenged women to
come forward and they came racing
forward okay another empowering thing
which people don't generally consider
necessarily in fact some people don't
even consider it that good no-fault
divorce yes I don't have women to leave
right and it's it's very interesting
that you know I constantly get women
saying that's the problem if it hadn't
been making divorce easier then all
these things wouldn't have happened we'd
be more stable it all went together you
cannot rearrange society so that
families are more stable than they were
before but the interesting thing to me
about no-fault divorce is that it
presumed in the way it was structured
that alimony would be this temporary
thing until women could go out and get
jobs and support themselves well that
seems very fair
but if a woman has been working at home
for 30 years while her husband was
building a law career or moving up on
the Union level at his job or whatever
he's doing it's totally unbalanced it
was really a signal that was sent to
women saying you know this we might
pretend the traditional to ivory is
great but we're not going to really
value it and again in the 90s when
welfare was eliminated for all practical
purposes another sort of signal saying
1996 welfare reform at poor yeah poor
women you know we put no value on the
idea of your staying home with your kids
so although on the one sense there's
always been this cry for let's return to
that great old standard in which the
moms stand with the kids
in fact Society we wanted welfare to
work yeah we've sent the opposite
signals entirely to women that you
better be able to take care of yourself
now what's interesting about that is a
lot of the people sending those signals
about about being able to stay at home
and why that was the the would probably
be the same people who said no-fault
divorce was a bad thing and created
instability in the family and look where
we are today you have a fascinating
profile in the book about Phyllis
Schlafly who is generally considered by
those who recall them all the tumult at
the moment as being this very
conservative women should stay at home
traditional mothers are the best
traditional lives are the best opponent
of the ER a all of that but she wasn't
quite what she seemed delish Lafley
knocks me out I mean there is this woman
I have seen very few women who were is
uber liberated this village lovely was
she had all these kids she taught them
she breastfed them taught them how to
read before they went to school she
stopped the ER a she wrote about six
books and she went to law school all at
the same time she was running around all
over the place she wasn't young when she
did that no no she was she was well into
her 40s and and her husband obviously
either supported it or or was was
willing to let it happen but women were
driven then the movement the women's
movement were just driven mad by this
woman who was coming in and yelling at
them about traditional values when she
is you know she has got far more stuff
more irons in the fire than most
never did and some of them claim to me
that she would always say in the green
room before a debate or whatever you
know I never could have done all this
stuff without the women's movement but
she would never say that publicly but
it's pretty clearly true it's pretty
clearly true title nine is now to anyone
who thinks about it at all thinks about
it something that allows girls to play
sports but it was a bigger deal than
that at the time oh yeah I mean I don't
think they were actually even thinking
about sports when title nine passed and
with Edith green really one who passed
the whole the whole new law equalized
giving women equal rights to offend the
federal aid federal federally funded
education if your school got federal
money you had to give equal rights to
your women on everything on board and no
one at the time thought well that would
mean particularly baseball you know they
were thinking about medical school
scholarships and all that kind of stuff
and that was Edith green and Daniel
Moynihan said this is the most important
thing we've done you know since World
War two did it work as intended it did
in so many ways and you know in fact if
one way one looks at now is that we have
all these stories about oh my lord
what's happened to our boys women have
done so well in college 56 percent of
the college students now are women and
they do better than men do and so we
worry about the men no and yet the Equal
Rights Amendment which was I recalled as
being the animating force we're roughly
the same age animating force especially
at the set of the 70s or the late 60s
but the seventies really that it was
going to be ratified across the country
and it was the big moment but it never
quite got to the big moment never quite
got there you know it's so interesting
when you look at it the reason I'm sure
that it never quite got there is because
the women who first drafted that and
fought so hard for that amendment
it never seemed conceivable to them that
you would eliminate all of the laws that
kept women apart and separate and gave
them less of a chance and unequal ground
on which to stand without some great
cosmic amendment but in fact by the time
those last States were coming up to a
boat it was very hard to explain what
this was going to do to
things better for women people had these
grand theories that you know once you
had it then you could look at wage
differentials and argue that action had
to be taken to eliminate the gab and
there were theories generally about how
this might work out but they were very
kind of vague
whereas Phyllis Schlafly was bounding
around making up these horrible
possibilities but it's very hard to
prove not to disprove a negative and an
NPO children sleep together yes this is
going to eliminate men and women's
bathrooms they'll all be unisex well
prove to me where that's not going to
happen you know this will eliminate the
Girl Scouts this was a very effective
art that's if it was very effective and
it's such a general amendment it was
very hard to argue one way or the other
on the other hand the other side is
saying well and we need this because
it's a symbol that do you know yet and
was er a even necessary in the end by
the time it got to this point where it
needed all this ratification hadn't so
much else happened that maybe it was
just symbolic I think you could argue
that it was either symbolic or at least
in the short term it was the people who
would still like to see it come back
keep saying well if you've got it in the
Constitution you're protected in a
special way against the future it's been
my experience that if people want to
change something they're going to change
it and if there's popular math behind it
that'll happen but it certainly would
not be on my list of the top 10 things
to do right now for the country what
would be on your list the real absolute
big humongous biggie that you see in the
book is that we transform society we've
created a society now where half of the
workforce is female where very few
families can conceivably get along
without women's paycheck and women's
participation and work and we did that
all without ever trying to figure out
who was going to take care of the kids
that is just a humongous humongous story
to me it was something that somehow got
overlooked in the whole women's movement
you know I remember when I was in
college we talked a little bit the
revolution you know the revolution
revolution yeah who knew what it was and
I don't think we actually had expected
it to come but if you had I totally
expected that by the time I was into my
career you'd have a world in which jobs
were flexible and people could go in and
out of jobs without losing career pole
and that husbands and wives might share
jobs or that it'd be very common for
guys to decide to stay home and that all
these things would just work and of
course that there be quality daycare
would be available all over the place
naturally I mean if you had told me none
of those things were going to happen I
would have been so shocked you wrote
about this woman who or it's a couple of
couples who tried to like climb a little
mini kommune
together and everybody was going to be
equivalent and that didn't it worked out
no the commune thing was you know a lot
of people had that thought that this is
the answer who's going to do the dishes
we'll take care of the kids but they'll
have a whole bunch of people and some
will want to do that there have also
been people have written in The Times
about women and husbands were attempting
to work out a deal where there really
have equal sharing of everything and
it's hard it's many lists must be
written every day because apparently
although guys now have really in many
relationships I think stepped up to the
plate on childcare on household
activities and chores they are nowhere
near that and partly that is because
guys standards of domestic maintenance
are way way lower and this is true it's
so true there are a lot of women seeing
home going yeah right about the size or
at least they're really capable of
holding out for a lot longer on the
dishes or whatever if they're good at it
they're keeping it a secret what you're
saying so so the somehow overlooked in
this great revolution in when everything
changed was what would happen to the
kids so what has happened to the kids
well can i I cannot give all the big
story things that surprised me most the
one that I had forgotten or maybe never
knew was that in 1971 Congress passed a
national entitlement a bipartisan bill
creating a national system that would
give every family the right to quality
early childhood education and
after-school programs which would be
free to the poor subsidized for the
middle class available for wealthier
people who wanted to pay for them and
thought they were doing it with the
Nixon administration's cooperation and
then we're sort of stun
when Nixon vetoed it why did he veto it
well funny is Pat Buchanan that who was
in the White House and it turned out
this Pat Buchanan is so proud that he
was one of the facilitators of the
destruction for early childhood
education in this country they they what
they didn't want Nixon to say it's
because it's too expensive because then
they were afraid that said that it would
be a pilot program it would sneak in
there they wanted a statement that the
national government the government in
general had no business getting involved
in the family in this way in terms of
child rearing and they wanted that to be
a political and social marker so the Pat
Buchanan's in the administration wanted
the political social marker but in
reality what Richard Nixon wanted was
not to spend this money it was more of a
fiscal decision or was it a little about
its you know it's so interesting I
interviewed so many people about that so
many perplex people some of them thought
well what he really wanted was to send a
message the right-wing because he was
going to China and he wanted to balance
it out nobody really knows what was on
Richard Nixon's mind the finances which
would which were certainly daunting even
then did not seem to be uppermost in the
minds of the people who were concerned
about this thing was away
well Ford arrived Jimmy Carter arrives
this that comes back well it almost
comes back the the sponsors of it met
and said well maybe we'll do it with
Ford but the economy was bad and they
thought well forward would be to it
because of economic reasons and they had
thought they had the bit and they
thought let's wait until the next
election maybe we'll get a Democratic
president it'll be interest either that
year suddenly Congress was deluge dwith
outrage letters mostly from the
Heartland from people saying you're
trying to pass this bill and it's a
communist bill we're going to let kids
form labor unions it's going to outlaw
taking kids to church all this
outrageous stuff but really really angry
letters and they got thousands of them
and nobody ever got thousands of letters
back then it was hard to write a letter
there was no email so it would just
chopped and terrified everybody and it
really clamped the thing down
forever that was really the end so clamp
that down did it also clamped down the
idea that this kind of change was needed
I mean did people then begin to say well
we've given them everything they need
why don't we go to they keep coming back
to the well I think there comes a time
in which you just separate if you look
right now I mean I would say right now
if you went to Congress and said is a
general theory of life do you think we
should have an entitlement to quality
early childhood education for everyone
who wants it they would say yes these
guys can't even get a health bill it's
just the economics of it are so daunting
and I and I do think also if you
remember back in the day the Republicans
were the more liberal party when it came
to a lot of social issues like women's
rights like family planning things like
that and the Democrats which really came
out of the Catholic cities were much
more conservative in the 60s you saw the
parties sort of moving in opposite
directions this period in the early 70s
when most of the women's legislation was
passed when the ER a was passed through
Congress when child care was entitled
temporarily that was sort of the moment
when they passed each other and they
were all kind of sitting there together
in the middle before they went in their
opposite directions
I was really particularly interested in
the chapter you write in this book about
the the clash between the civil rights
movement and the women's right movement
you would think you would think they
would be stuck with one another when I
wrote my book about breakthroughs in
American politics and black politics I
just was able to touch on this in
passing but one of the things that I
remember was that when shirley Chisholm
ran for president 1972 and among little
black girls it was a very exciting
moment but I read that in fact it was in
the Congressional Black Caucus which
said either she's entitled to her
delusions they were they thought she was
hallucinatory she did not have support
among african-american men and now she
didn't do well I'm a Libra 5% or
something but still this breakthrough
moment is this this historic moment
which everyone remembers so fondly
was that really what welcomed when
shirley Chisholm said that she had had
more grief for being a woman than for
being an african-american she was
speaking out of her own experience which
was mainly in politics
in a district in a borough that was
mainly african-american she did not get
many grief periods from white folk when
she was running for office yeah she ran
against a guy who ran and the black guy
of course is saying you know we need a
man and you know we need a man here in
Congress for Brooklyn uh and the civil
rights entire movement you know was sort
of drenched with this sort of issue this
kind of sexual tension that among young
women I don't think much came to the
fore because they were so committed to
the cause but among older black women
with people like Ella Baker you know who
had been in the movement forever would
really been there forever elevator with
Ella Baker was basically the woman who
founded snick this Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee she was a
long-term organizer she had this great
vision she was one of the very few
visionaries who saw the civil rights
movement as a way not just to empower
black people but to kind of remake the
country in a way that gave everybody a
voice yet the civil rights movement when
you hear at the tail of it that the role
of heroes you see very few women's names
mentioned and any school child can tell
you well it was Martin Luther King and
maybe Ralph Abernathy and maybe Julian
Bond and Andrew young but it turns out
women were there women were not only
there women when the organizers would go
into southern towns these small towns
and you think oh my lord how could
anybody be brave enough to stand up in
these small towns where you knew there
was going to be violence if you raised
your hand first and said I'll register
it was almost always the women who stood
up and it wasn't I want to separate it
out because there are the experiences of
the african-american women in the
movement dealing with the male leaders
and then they were the experiences of
white women in the movement the
african-american women in the movement
they were there they were doing the hard
work they were even pounding they were
like the Ella Baker's of the world yet
and yet we didn't see them say at the
iconic moments like at the march on
Washington you didn't that was to me one
of the most shocking stories about this
line in the march on Washington and you
remember any my god the great moment
Rosa Parks marched with the wise all the
great women
Daisy bate
these people marched with the wives and
when they got to the platform they just
sat there they no woman was allowed to
speak and they could say we got enough
people you know we let Marion Anderson
sing what do you mean there are no women
the unions are represented there are
women in the unions um it was it's
shocking when you think back about it
there was no woman in the leadership who
went to talk to the president it's a
loss in the only person you saw in these
old black-and-white photographs was
Dorothy Height where yeah trademark hat
she was allowed for the photographs and
because she represented the women the
one woman but Dorothy and Dorothy Height
who had said frequently will this we do
what to empower the men there's nothing
black women want more than to empower
our men just see men that are strong
leaders once you got to this large
Dorothy Height is running around saying
hey guys you know can we have a woman
here please and they know nobody she was
as shocked as anyone why do you think
that was I think there was that you know
desire form you know to empower men and
well Andrew Young said you know we lived
our lives with all these strong women in
our lives and they were very daunting
and you know really when we get past
that and move on and you know it was
easier for us in that way I think there
was those moments so we're women just
filing papers and typing or were they
actually on the front lines
well black women in the movement were
certainly on the front lines there was
no place they weren't as I said they
worked so many of them you know you if
any Lou Hamer you know being beaten in
jail and you know being thrown out of
her house there were people having their
businesses ruined having shotgun blast
through their window the women were
always on the front lines the black
women in the south white women except
for those few who had been there from
the day and we're just deeply ingrained
many of them tended to come in toward
Mississippi summer toward toward that
period and there was just this sense on
the part of the movement that this was
just trouble you know there's no secret
about that Mississippi Freedom Summer a
lot of women got in their cars white
women white man too but they drove south
and but it was a complicated thing when
it was a white woman in an office with
all of these black men and all of a
sudden was fraught right it was
triply fraud it was fraught in the sense
of danger because there was nothing that
made the white community nuts faster
than any seeing of a white woman with a
black man and everybody who had lived in
that area knew that that was just the
key to disaster of the first order any
sort of site like that so in that sense
they were a dangerous and black women
who had fought alongside the men for all
this period all this long time suddenly
saw these young white women come in and
they were very taken with the bravery of
the civil rights movement the guys were
very taken with these new women coming
in and there were a lot of romances
between white women and black guys and
the black women were sort of left on the
side and that was incredibly painful for
them so there were all these things
going on it was very very very fraught
lots of lots and lots of tensions we're
going to get to the rest of them and
talk about the rest of the 50 years
right when we come back from this break
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with Gail Collins and Gwen
Ifill in a moment fox news contributor
michelle malkin is our guest this
weekend on book tv's in-depth the
blogger columnist and author of four
books including the best-selling culture
of corruption takes your calls emails
and tweets three hours with michelle
malkin sunday live at noon eastern on
book TV after words with Gail Collins
and Gwen Ifill continues welcome
afterwards I'm sitting here talking with
Gail Collins the author of the new book
when everything changed the amazing
journey of American women from 1960 to
the present we are talking about the
tensions within the civil rights
movement but there were also always it
seems to me tensions between the women's
rights movement and black women in
general
I remember being asked over and over
again oh you're one first are you glad
first that got so tiresome but that was
the essential war that was going on it
was so complicated for black women back
then because you did have the black guys
behaving very badly on a number of Matic
occasions just going into this period
some of them with okay we're going to do
this thing now will we create our
African past and please stand three
paces behind me while I'm walking it'll
empower us both wait and see and and
then you had the women within the
women's movement were very much divided
between reformers who wanted to give
women an equal playing field but didn't
want to change society just wanted our
half and the women who wanted to really
transform the whole society just to go
back and figure out how we got to the
subservient place and then just change
it all and those weirdly it was the
reformers who lack women tended to
gravitate more to because there were
very interested in issues like equal pay
that was a very big deal but these
complicated things about you know Fannie
Lou Hamer kept saying I do not want to
be liberated from my size 18 shoo
husband I like and find the way he is so
that that was the issues there were very
difficult of course the white women in
the movement also had terrible times
with the white guys who had been were in
the anti-war movement who were also sort
of feeling their macho oats at that time
and of course it wasn't all of them
please all the guys that were there most
of you I we were all great but a certain
sliver of the leadership was really
obnoxious and really hated the idea that
women had a problem because if women had
a problem then they were the problem it
just takes a little is very hard very
and the sliver was so bad and so do me
two women that I think much of the
really kind of over-the-top rhetoric of
the women in the movement had to do with
their reaction against the men in the
movement who were being so crazy but as
with all movements there are internal
tensions as well and generational ones
we're roughly the same generation as I
pointed out before but very young
general a very young generation but
there are shockingly women younger than
we amazing amazing and they look at they
looked at a lot of what we did and said
what does that have to do even now what
does that have to do with me and that
this is not new to now this has always
been the case well you know there's two
levels to that on the level of so many
women basically want to be thanked one
younger women to him and say oh you know
I realized now I would never be here
doing what I'm doing today if it wasn't
for all your struggles thank you so much
and that would be nice I guess but to me
it is such a trip the idea that the
younger generation was born just
presuming that they can do whatever they
set out to do and that that's the way of
the world that to me is not a bad thing
that is just incredibly neat on the
subject of whether or not it would be
better if they knew more of their
history it's I just think it's so
empowering just to realize that the
entire churning of the history of the
planet came to a point that created the
platform for them and that that's such a
great story I would love them to know it
on that level alone I talked to a
college professor who runs a Women's
Center at a university in the Midwest in
the middle of the height of the Hillary
Clinton campaign and she said that when
she talked to her young women students
about that campaign their response was
she reminds me of my mother now that
wasn't very empowering and this is not
what they necessarily wanted to be I
guess this was taken as a bad thing that
she minded but what did what how did
that happen where did that shift happen
well you know I thought Susan Faludi had
a really great up Adenauer paper during
the whole Hillary thing and she wrote it
at that point you will remember when
suddenly everything turned again and
Hillary started just campaigning like
gangbusters and pulled ahead of
Bhama in those sort of Midwestern states
that were toward the end and everyone
said oh this must be racism people we're
looking at obama thinking no black guy
and she said well I think it's something
else you know what the problem for women
has always been that they tend to
parachute in like a hall monitor
there the reformer and here we are
everyone has been very bad and now I'm
going to fix things and make everybody
behave and the guy sort of intuitively
knew that the people who can be made to
behave was them and there was always
that kind of sense of you know standing
back and when you did when you saw
Hillary in those last day she was so not
that she was so much in the ditch with
everybody fighting and scrapping and I
think created a whole new way for women
to campaign and you see it in the I
think in the future we'll see a lot more
of that but it's not a muscle wrote a
piece for the New York Times op-ed page
which caused quite a stir at the time
and Robert Morgan was jumped on board
and they were and the general gist of it
was it's not their turn anymore it's our
turn how can you deny us our turn that
was a subject of a lot of drama in the
middle of 2008 such so many women had
always thought that the moment at which
a woman was elected president will be
the Grail that will just point to the
point where we really made it that's the
moment that we'll say okay this all
happened and they were so sure she was
going to win I mean it did look at the
beginning as if there was just no choice
in the matter and then when she didn't I
mean and I look at that campaign frankly
and I see there was certainly sexism
just as there was certainly racism and I
always work under the assumption that 5%
of this country is stark-raving nuts
anyway so you know the fact that you're
going to see a lot of really bad
behavior no matter what happens but to
me Hillary Clinton lost because she had
bad planning of the early caucus days
this is not a big you know sexual know
there there are nutcrackers with steal
by yeah there were they were not
determine the outcome no I think
absolutely not I think if she had
planned the caucus dates better and had
had better organized campaign earlier on
she would have won and that's but she
did Wow
she may
normal I talked to a woman was very sad
toward the end of Hillary Clinton's
campaign because she had expected an
older woman that she at one point should
be able to dance at the inauguration of
a one president and that sadness
continued probably to drive a lot of the
hesitation over Barack Obama sometime
into the general election it's true but
they did get over it well they got over
right after Sarah Palin and the the
points swung women flock to Sarah Palin
20-point swing and then well the block
back but by short term flocking well
because it's about the issues at hand
and now well this always happens with
elections which is I guess the one good
thing about our interminable election
schedules here you always have these
points at which people just get tired
they get irritable or a new face comes
along and people always prefer the
non-existent alternative to the deeply
imperfect whatever it is you've got
there and and then they kind of wander
off but then they look at the new face
and the new face becomes deeply
imperfect and they come on back so I did
Sarah Palin is a very interesting story
in and of herself and I've written a lot
of times that I think she is genuinely
an heir to the women's movement and
Gloria Steinem called me once and said
well if that's true I'm shooting myself
tomorrow the end again but if you look
at Sarah Palin she has never been
constrained by her gender um lots of
other weird stuff going on there and you
know not a person I would recommend as a
political candidate for anything native
liberation was about allowing women to
be to have disagree and the idea that
once you got everybody liberated they
were all going to turn out to be these
great wonderful role models is that's
the parachuting in kind of theory I mean
the women are just as improved in
control is any winged seraphs Sarah
Palin is a role model not just a Gloria
Steinem role model so what you can't
limit that once you put them out of even
if you let them out of the box there's
much left it was a strong your
extraordinary person who I disagree with
on everything known to mankind but you
cannot just go there and say that's not
an amazing woman
let's talk about popular images because
I was one of those girls who sat there
in college in the 70s and watched Mary
Tyler Moore every Saturday night I went
out to
party afterward but I did stay home I
don't want you to feel sad for me I did
get out but I looked at Mary Tyler Moore
and I thought possibilities
impossibilities now contrast that to
Bonanza Bonanza was that when I watched
when I was a kid and it was this this
when you think back on you think what
were we thinking oh my lord you have
this big huge ranch it's run by this guy
he's got three sons he is a widower
three times over each of his sons has a
different mother they all died that sons
are constantly getting engaged role of a
little Joe I know my lord it is the road
to straight debt they would always die
the women would die before the first
commercial usually and it was just that
that whole period when you had westerns
on it was just such a message that girls
never have adventures unless it involves
getting kidnapped and then somebody
saves you it's hard you know go try
girls never did anything interesting in
any of these shows and you know I am
still to this day a huge fan of Buffy
the Vampire Slayer because it was just
so much the up Buffy rides alone she
really can't settle down with a guy cuz
she has to save the world every day you
know but there was no and even the even
the shows with female leads I get it
still played to this notion of secondary
status Oh [ __ ] it's mom points at some
point to the wall and there's a sampler
that says something like the woman is a
person who brings out the best in a man
and you know okay destiny of a woman is
to improve the man that's around who was
the mother and father knows best
oh yes Ellen she kind of walked into my
heels and pearls and walk back out oh
and Leave It to Beaver yes Leave It to
Beaver just settin you know and she
could high heels in the kitchen and even
the early Mary the Dick Van Dyke Show
you would see him Mary Tyler Moore who
did wear slacks after a while and that
was a huge fight people forget that the
producer oh my lord the first time she
showed up in slacks it was it's just
there was an outcry but she did do that
but she would be standing there with her
pearls on you know stirring the one
little pot the still yeah we we wish
that was even possible I wouldn't mind
one girl also cook but the stirring the
one little pot doesn't work so much so
we fast-forward to Mary Tyler Moore and
Murphy Brown I mean how
different could it be at a time when I
think and Dick Van Dyke they weren't
allowed to sleep in the same bed right
right but they were definitely married
but they had two little twin beds there
are these single women it's you know the
idea that a woman could be happy without
a man was and that was the Mary Tyler
Moore thing if you look at the early
Mary Tyler Moore as I watched the first
season over again when I was doing this
the early Mary Tyler Moore's are not
she's come there and she's just broken
up with her fiance and she's coming and
she had wrote is sit around every night
be wailing their single state and
talking about guys and it's not really
until the thing evolved over a couple of
years that you really establish this is
a woman they they arranged a theme song
yeah yeah you might even feel you might
just make it to you're gonna make it
after all yeah yeah yeah and she's she's
fine and she's happy and she's got a
full life
she clearly has sex uh she has friends
did you think so I wasn't so certain I'm
really did your big eyes there in the
morning or at the end they made a pretty
clear Marquis Brown definitely had
success she had a baby oh yeah
absolutely
now what does she represent that
remember she was a it was a big deal
involving Dan Quayle well he brown and a
child out of wedlock which now seems
quaint but at the time it was a big deal
you know you look back on it too and I
can understand where they were coming
from I mean you know they they were so
it was such a huge change and not the
massive number of women having children
out of wedlock was economically
problematic as these women for the most
part we're having a real hard time
moving themselves out of poverty and
sort of so to say to create this as a
great role model and to give it was a
little bit to me like the the Bristol
Palin moment at the convention I mean
you know God bless Bristol but to me
with that convention moment with Levi
coming in the two of them are holding it
basically said two young girls in
America was you know if you've got a
boyfriend if you get pregnant he will
clean up his act and he will show up at
family gatherings and everybody will
applaud you and it's just so as we see
now with Bristol not the way things are
the way things turn out well not so many
Republican women I talked to the
convention we're convinced this was a
statement on behalf of Family Values
that
instead of taking the the dreaded other
option of abortion that they would try
to build a family together it as and we
saw how it turned out in the end and and
then and perfectly most women who get
pregnant do not get have great jobs and
a guy who's been painting their house
for 27 years who's going to help take
care of the baby
and all the other stuff that happened
talking about Murphy ground that bristol
kaelin right no Bristol you know I I did
run into Bristol and her new role is the
teen pregnancy model for a clothing line
I think that these are choices isn't
that what this was all about it was all
about choices um I I do I've always
thought that it's very important if
you're a political person to keep your
family out of it in a really aggressive
violent way just completely totally
smack down on it and I was sorry that
that didn't happen with him how much of
what we've seen happen with these
woman's and in pop culture and with the
movement such as it is anymore at all
how much of this suffered from backlash
after a while it was kind of like are
you still talking about that well you
did have a backlash in the 70s um which
is one of the reasons the ER it was
defeated and when you look back on it
how could you blame the country I mean
my lord in like eight years time Nora
Ephron always says I think it's in the
book you know you feel so sorry for the
guys who got married under the old rules
and then suddenly one day it's like what
oh yeah your walk into your living room
and there's a consciousness-raising
meeting in which are based discussing
failure of husbands to give the proper
orgasms or something you know it's just
like what what happened here so it's not
surprising and especially traditional
housewives who had grown up thinking
they had the best possible role that
they were the winners of society
suddenly everybody's looking at them
like they're unemployed in about 5
seconds times so to me what was amazing
was that despite that kind of political
backlash you still saw Americans
constantly whenever the question was
clearly about fairness is it fair should
women be allowed to have equal credit
should they be allowed to go to medicals
anything that was fair they left on
board and women made incredible progress
in the 70s and 80s and in terms of
breaking down barriers getting is filing
lawsuits getting editorship sat
newspaper is getting a team and getting
getting into law school and getting
promoted in various places so although
there was for sure that backlash and you
could argue it helped create the sort of
Reagan Revolution on the right it when
it came to the fairness stuff the civil
rights movement had so transformed the
country except for instance look at
affirmative action that was very popular
for a while when it was seen as fairness
and then when it became defined for
women as well as for people of color as
something which someone was getting
something that somebody else was not it
wasn't evening the playing field it was
giving someone else a leg up all of a
sudden you would ask the same question
and get different answers when the
questions become complicated like that
or is it fair to that husband should you
know have to do more work at home when
they're working all day and we get all
the sort of complicated stuff then it
was it fair the children should not have
anybody at home for them during the day
then then people branch out and have
arguments and stuff like that but when
the clear crystal clear fairness issues
come along this country is very sure
what side it's on you talk about a men
who signed on for one thing and ended up
with another thing how much in reality
did men's role shift during this period
of amazing change it did so much and you
know um I have a story that I tell so
constantly I'm going to have to give
them money for it at some point
something their royalties are coming
through but you know Steve Weisman used
to be on the editorial board and
Elizabeth beyou Miller who was White
House correspondent is when I'm married
to each other
they're married to each other when I was
on the editorial board they were both in
New York they had young children and
Elizabeth had been sent off to Kosovo
and Steve came in one day and just
looked like a dead person I've never
seen it and I said what is wrong with
you and he said with great tragedy in
his voice my wife's in Albania and the
hamster is missing I hope that's gonna
be my next book it's going to be the men
over the last next 50 years and it's my
wife as well baby and the hamster is
missing guys he had this huge enormous
change in their lives um and part of it
is economic you know guys do now totally
expect from the
part that their partner whoever they
marry is going to work with them I
remember when they because the stories
of while back about Yale students women
who decided they didn't want to work
after they had babies and they were
going to retire at that point we had a
guy in the board he lost quite an uproar
yeah Nick poolish was on our board I was
looking for somebody to write about it
from some great feminist viewpoint and
so he wrote this great piece thing on
behalf of all the young males in America
at Yale students excuse me were we
consulted about this because I mean I
think I would have taken entirely
different life course if I thought that
whoever I was going to marry was never
going to work
and that's true you don't you know you
can't you need both the partnership sets
of marriage I think is much more intense
now than ever in the sense that this is
a joint economic project that everybody
will work on together
you mentioned the boy crisis sticking
with the guys for a minute earlier it
was that real or was that just something
that happens that when all of a sudden
power ships from from one gender to
another that all of a sudden we just
begin to realize you think was sort of
funny like you know there are only two
sexes for society is sitting is that
what why why I I'm never going to be
perfectly perfect but it is true that
girls do so much better in school now
everywhere I go people tell me that then
guys doubt that ah I don't know and it
doesn't really translate into the
outside world so far because I do think
that the tension between work and family
is such that women do have a much harder
time when competition gets fierce
keeping up with all this stuff at the
same time but there is something going
on there and I say God bless if people
want to try to figure out how to make
boys succeed better I mean but it is
just so funny this is like them what it
was girls it was like oh yeah it's so
true they should be courage more you
know and now it's like oh my god how
long did it take you to write this book
that's about five years I think and when
you were on this journey and you very
generously give credit to researchers
who interviewed a lot of people for you
and and spread this beyond just the
original notions to get these voices
poor the women or the heroines of this
piece not only the women who we've all
heard of but the women we haven't heard
of especially the ones
- I kinda said there's one woman that I
interviewed that I just so fell in love
with when lorena weeks who is this right
now little bitty elderly woman in rural
Georgia and in the early sixties she was
she and her mother her father and mother
had died when she was very young and she
had raised her brother and sister and
she would send them off to school and
she would go to work at a restaurant and
then after they got home she would leave
the restaurant take a bus and work
overnight as a telephone operator just
killing herself fell in love madly in
love with her husband the guy named
Billy weeks and they both so wanted to
send their kids to college and they
didn't have much money and Lorena's
working as a clerk at the spell south
and this job comes up for a Rooter which
no one had ever heard of but basically
was just keeping the equipment in the
office orderly and she applied for it
and they said this is not for a woman
and her Union said no this is a
breadwinners job not for you pays too
much and she saw a little sign for the
Equal Opportunities Commission and she
complained and um never a popular mother
never a popular move and it turned out
law in Georgia is in many states that
women cannot have jobs we have to lift
more than 30 pounds and there was the
thing that you had to get around that
weighed 30 pounds you had it on a dolly
so you were pushing it and poor Laura is
coming out every morning and picking up
her 40 pound typewriter and sitting it
on the desk and that was no problem
anyway she sued now helped her she
fought for years on this suit and I'm
like all the women in history who just
stand up when there is nobody around
them saying you go girl you know we have
meetings and Cheer her husband was sort
of embarrassed her kids were sort of
nonplussed and every work hated her they
didn't they did the national
organization of women find her did she
find that she found them and one of the
things that they were doing at that very
early stage was they were trying to
assign lawyers to cases I mean the
closest lawyer for her was a volunteer
from Louisiana a woman named Sylvia
Roberts and it was all very it's just
adorable I love that part of the book
these women chart we know you said no
computers you're nailing things all over
the place and how hard they worked with
nothing but it took her
for years and finally she did when she
got the job she got back pay uh and the
kids all went to college and did very
well and she said that when she went to
her local office to apply for Social
Security the woman looked at it and said
I have never seen such a large income
statement for a woman in my life and it
was just yeah well she is so cool
she remind me a lot of lilly Ledbetter
who is course the current version are
there other women who we should know
about who you write about in ways that
we didn't necessarily recognize at the
time I started there's a woman named
Margaret ray Wald who was in Washington
who was just typical so typical of her
generation that she was a lawyer she
really broke through in that way but she
had no real expectations that the world
was going to change for she was a little
bit too early she always wanted to be a
judge who ended up working for the tax
department and you know some secondary
way and training guys who all got
promoted above her and she started
working through women's groups for equal
rights stuff for the ära and she was the
one of all of these people who was like
the champion letter writer and you just
forget what the world was like before
computers and Xerox machines Facebook
somebody told me that that you know she
would have this huge long line of
letters and then she had a sponge and
she would go and let all the envelopes
and knock them down sheep this forever
anytime anything came up in Congress she
would mobilize all of these women and
they were all send letters and she's
sort of standing there on the alert
through all this time women like this
nobody has ever heard of and just gave
me so much pleasure to be able to write
about them in this book now these women
were heroines but it wasn't without cost
no and you know another reason I was so
happy to write this book is often when I
go around people will ask me a question
that basically is an invitation to tell
about my suffering in the world as I
have lunged for a record bootstrap yeah
my port what horrible things happen to
me in fact it was exactly the opposite I
sort of came sailing into this newly
open window that was opened about three
seconds before by women about three
seconds older than me who filed the
suits and
ever really got anything for it they
were not the ones who tended to get
promoted when companies said okay you're
right we're going to have to promote
women it would always be the next women
who got the promotions and these first
women who did so much never got
recognized I never got rewarded for it
so it's a real pleasure to be able to
honor them with this book before we go
tell us about you
you've mentioned how you slid over not
slid but you came into the way yeah but
but but you you made history and clearly
that's not what you set out to do but
something something about you something
about opportunity something about the
times not the New York Times but the
times we live in allowed this to happen
yeah and you know and um also everybody
my age I bet a night I bet you two don't
know anything about your parents but we
are almost all the children of really
conservative fathers who yet when they
saw their daughters good nobody gonna
stand in the way of my daughter gonna do
whatever she was I told my father an
accidental feminists to give us he
didn't realize when he told the boys
they could do anything they wanted that
the girls would say okay you must be
speaking to me too they always you to
say that a conservative is a liberal
who's been mugged I would say a liberal
is a conservative who's just had twin
daughters I mean that's sort of the same
way around so it prepared you being at
home being raised by this this
conservative man who saw possibilities
for you and maybe uh a mother who looked
at you and thought well but they chose I
didn't have I want her to it's true my
mother did want to be a journalist and
had to drop out of school because of the
war and stuff like that and um you know
I
people also keep asking me for like the
story of when my mother said no you go
in there and knock them down and it
wasn't that kind of a family my mother
is a kind of person who would always say
Wow is that great I can't believe it
look at that sentence what a good sense
this is fantastic look at this piece you
could do that you could do that and it
was just a very kind of positive
empowering and there certainly wasn't
any sense that you couldn't do stuff
every step that you did you took to get
where you are today did you ever stop
and say well of course naturally or did
you stop and say wait until they find
out what they've done
there was a bit of both this editorial
page editor thing was kind of definitely
like that was oh my gosh well but when
they offered it to me how rains first
broached it to me he was the editor at
the time and he said be the time there
you are and and he said to me you know
you always write the stuff about women
you know in history and you could be
like a paragraph or so let you do this
and I thought gosh is that that he
actually say that he said this is you
can make history if you do this yeah he
did and I thought well there are not
that many opportunities to be the first
woman for stuff anymore I don't think
anybody's going to offer me
baseball commissioner so this might you
know this is great I could do this thing
and it was a great kind of leader I
still waiting for football commissioner
I know sorry about what she didn't do
much with her life that what okay so
that way you look back on this now that
this book is done which it's it's off
your back um what do you think that
women reading it now who did not live
through the 60s and 70s who take a lot
of this for granted what it what is it
they should take away from this I'd like
them to think about the power of all
these women and sort of all these lives
and sort of the texture of the history
that we live through and how they come
out of it organically it's like if you
see where you sprang from it's always
empowering if you see the stuff that
happened it's not like oh my god how
much they suffered oh my lord that's
terrible but wow this is the story and
this is such a neat story definitely
things undone left to be done but what a
fantastically neat time we lived in it
it's a great story and it's a great read
Gail Collins when everything changed the
amazing journey of American women from
1960 to the present I look forward to
sitting in my Saturday mornings with my
coffee reading your column thank you so
much